The Nun is a big step forward for The Conjuring
series, giving the shared universe of horror
movies its biggest opening weekend yet.
The third franchise sub-series after The Conjuring
and Annabelle movies, The Nun works harder
than any of its predecessors to make connections
to the films that came before it.
Whether it's a visual reference to a past
movie, the conclusion of a series-long plot,
or the presence of the demon Valak's name
all over the place, the movie has plenty to
offer for eagle-eyed viewers looking for clues
about how everything connects.
If you watched the spooky movie through your
fingers, we've got you covered - here are
some small details you might've missed in
The Nun.
Original creation
The Nun is the fifth entry in the expanding
Conjuring universe, and it asserts itself
within that continuity in a variety of ways.
For one, the movie's opening scene about two
sisters in the St. Cartas Abbey fighting off
the demon nun features an almost-perfect recreation
of the post-credits scene of Annabelle: Creation,
which teased the demon nun spinoff in 2017.
In The Nun, it's revealed that the spooky
spectre coming down the hall is pursuing Sister
Victoria, who sacrifices herself to keep the
demon from possessing her and entering the
real world.
Curiously, The Nun lacks a similar post-credits
sequence of its own.
For whatever reason, it looks like the series'
producers don't want to give people any hints
of what's to come before Conjuring 3, Annabelle
3, or their next spinoff, The Crooked Man.
Demonic DJ
After Father Burke and Sister Irene arrive
at the abbey for an overnight stay, their
sleep is interrupted by Valak, which proves
itself to be a real nuisance of a demon.
Instead of killing everyone immediately, the
monster's first move is to wake Burke up in
the middle of the night by blaring the abbey
radio with an on-the-nose song choice.
Specifically, the radio that interrupts Burke's
slumber is playing Jo Stafford's version of
the tune "You Belong to Me," which means exactly
what it sounds like it means.
Real subtle, Valak.
Precious memories
Visible in the background of Irene and Burke's
first dinner in the abbey is a photograph
that will be familiar to anyone who watched
Annabelle: Creation.
The black-and-white snapshot was originally
referenced by Sister Charlotte in the demon
doll story, which chronologically takes place
in 1955, three years after the events of The
Nun.
The photo shows Sister Charlotte alongside
three nuns of the St. Cartas Abbey, whom she
says she became very close to at some point
in the past.
Those relationships aren't built on in The
Nun though, since by the time Irene and Burke
arrive at the abbey in 1952, every one of
the nuns Charlotte knew is presumably dead.
Considering what we learn about the abbey,
it's almost a little jarring to see the Sisters
there ever having a moment of levity.
Does Charlotte in 1955 even know her friends
are dead, or that they gave their lives for
such important work?
It doesn't seem that way.
She doesn't even recognize the face of Valak
that haunts her copy of the photograph, and
seems to have no idea how lucky she is to
have made it out alive.
What's your name?
Supernatural activity is at work in The Nun
before Burke and Irene ever arrive at the
abbey.
If you look closely, you can see the demon's
name pop up in the world around them - a strange
phenomenon that seems to surround the demon's
activity.
As Burke and Irene prepare to embark for the
abbey with their local guide Maurice, Burke
accidentally places his bags in the back of
an unrelated truck.
It's a humorous moment, except for one odd
thing: the vehicle's license plate.
Aside from a few junk letters and numbers
breaking up the sequence, the plate for the
most part reads "VALAK."
The demon's name can also be partially seen
in Irene's introductory scene, spelled out
backwards and vertically on the wall of her
school classroom.
Valak's presence did the same thing in The
Conjuring 2.
It's a weird and unexplained phenomenon, considering
that the demon's name is its biggest weakness.
For some reason or another, Valak can't stop
spilling the beans.
Pazuzu style
Like a lot of demon-centric horror movies,
The Nun owes a lot to The Exorcist.
At least one frightening image in the movie
is a very clear visual reference to that 70s
classic.
As Father Burke lays trapped in a wooden coffin,
buried alive in the abbey's graveyard, he
is grabbed from behind by Valak.
As the demon claws at Burke's face, the audience
can briefly see the twisted visage of the
demon flash within the darkness beside Burke.
The moment is highly reminiscent of The Exorcist,
with that movie's demon appearing in snarling,
near-subliminal flash frames.
In both movies, the quick glimpses at the
faces of the demons are blink-and-you'll-miss-it
moments, making them some of the scariest
parts of either one.
Conjuring a connection
The Nun brings its story full circle in its
final minutes, cutting from Romania in 1952
to Wakefield, Massachusetts, 20 years later.
This postscript scene loops the finale of
The Nun back into the very first Conjuring
movie, revealing that the lecture given by
Ed and Lorraine Warren in that film was all
along referring to an encounter the couple
had with Maurice, aka "Frenchie."
Just before the epilogue kicks in, Maurice
is revealed to have been possessed by Valak
during the final battle in the abbey's catacombs.
It makes for a pretty sad end to the otherwise
charming tour guide.
"So what happened to Maurice?"
"Well he tried… gun on himself."
The ending of The Nun briefly recreates The
Conjuring's scene, using brand new footage
of The Nun's Maurice, played by Jonas Bloquet
in place of the original actor.
It's a moment that solidifies The Nun's connection
to the first two Conjuring movies, revealing
that the Warrens' visions of the demon nun
were implanted into them by their encounter
with the possessed Maurice.
What began in Romania in 1952 ultimately comes
to an end in 1977 London, when the Warrens
decisively banish Valak from the earthly realm
- for now, at least.